vieillir ça plaît davantage d'accidents
premier d'au moins besoin de dormir ou
talent y est c'est comme ça que
l'ancêtre joe thornton a félicité son
ancien coéquipier patrick marleau après
qu'il a battu le record de goldie à 2667
matches joués reste plus à marlowe que
d'obtenir une photo de lui avec la
nouvelle merveille collection des vieux
qui réussissent y en a plein tom brady
vieillir six images récentes de chez web
mais problème c'est pas des vieux c'est
les sportifs qui s'accroche à l'idée que
leurs meilleurs jours sont encore devant
la liste est longue et elle fait mal
sitôt vu ton nom sur la liste 50
informer sur les aubaines sont les
veilleurs et prends ta retraite beaucoup
de partisans du canadien ont finalement
découvert cette année les effets du
vieillissement actif sur leurs joueurs
préférés
surtout si ton joueur préféré est un
leader naturel qu'il n'aime pas beaucoup
parler aux médias et qu'il lui reste
encore cinq saisons à un salaire moyen
qui en fait un des deux mieux payés de
l'organisation parce que c'est vrai égal
pour sherweb rigueur chez wever tant
qu'il y aura une grosse garnotte
pourquoi il prendrait sa retraite et
carey price gang a encore 10 2 5
millions de dollars par année
même s'ils arrêtent plus que des ballons
plage la grogne monte déjà sur les
réseaux sociaux face à leur déclin mais
c'est juste le début
yop pas de retour en arrière y'a pas
d'athlètes qui soudainement retrouve ses
jambes de 20 ans à 35
ça peut juste à être égale ou pire l'an
prochain jamais meilleurs et en tant que
partisan ou organisation il te reste
qu'une chose à faire amorcer tondeuse
les cinq phases du drama voix pour les
cinq phases du deuil sportif le tennis
est encore longue c'est juste une
mauvaise passe la colonne ya pas de
coeur y en eu jamais eu
est-ce qu'on peut juste le domp et à
laval comme colin un marchandage du 9
janvier avons tout réglé
et si on changeait son entraîneur
la dépression je vais regarder les
matchs des sénateurs à la place
l'acceptation mois on ne substitue luxe
pour que d'un primo l'épreuve des
chiffres au basketball five to be est
inventé une statistique pour faire
comprendre aux fans que leur joueur
préféré est sur une pente descendante et
l'on appelait le corps mais l'eau parce
que quand mélo anthony pensait encore
d'être un joueur d'impact
alors qu'ils avaient vraiment a pris un
coup de vieux est ce que ça montre c'est
que même si tu es lo green jobs staff
est inéluctable
[Musique]
une des solutions pour se débarrasser
d'un joueur qui ne comprend pas que sa
carrière est terminée c'est de lui
organiser une cérémonie après chaque
rencontre
ça fonctionnait pour kobe bryant et
derek jitter pourquoi pas avec le web on
est déjà souligné deux fois cette année
son millième marche on pourrait
commencer à faire l'un des camps mis les
uns 1000 et 2000 et 3000 kg a les seins
parce que quand on fait remarquer le
vrai problème c'est que peu de solutions
pour les athlètes qui veulent continuer
de compétitionner
si tous les sports à 20 circuit senior
bien organisés comme celui du golfe
peut-être que ça donnerait le goût à
certains de quitter un peu plus tôt au
foot ça pourrait ressembler au pro bowl
comme tous les joueurs encore et le
cerveau un brin amoché il pourrait juste
se faire des passes sens plaqués et tom
brady pourrait enfin sortir de nos vies
et gagné le super bowl de parement
pourrait faire ça tu pas son double
aussi aux des boues mains d'un côté les
coureurs et de l'autre pour les gones
les pumas les plus mous merci d'avoir
été là et si vous êtes vieux mais jeunes
de coeur
laissez-nous un jeune sans manches et
web et lost en bas à gauche se prend ta
souris tranquillement qui tu viens
mettre le curseur sur le pouce
m'entendent sujet